[Music]
there's a huge racial disparity in the
net worth of americans
in 2016 the median net worth of black
households was about 17 thousand dollars
for white households that figure was 171
thousand
about 10 times as much one of the
drivers of that wealth gap
is redlining the practice of mortgage
lenders denying loans to people
based on their race or where they live
with those areas marked with
red lines on maps although the practice
was outlawed
in 1968 its effects are still being felt
today
something entrepreneurs and activists
are trying to reverse
what was auburn avenue well it was
everything it was
black excellence it was black commerce
in it a century ago
kimberly alexander's family business was
a fixture here
there was a period of time after
desegregation where businesses shuttered
and
left because they had opportunity
elsewhere and
some people thought the grass was
greener on the other side and so
unfortunately that left a lot of
buildings plated and the area played it
and redlined and redlined the federal
government began the practice of
redlining in the 1930s outlining in red
ink on maps
areas deemed hazardous often home to
sizable black minority and
immigrant populations based on that
mortgage lenders would deny
loans to low-income minorities in those
neighborhoods causing disinvestment
and placing home ownership out of reach
for people of color
i think you see it in every city in
america i mean this is where
the basis of segregated neighborhoods
remains to this day
councilman amir farooqi represents this
district half of which is enjoying the
bloom of reinvestment
the other still blighted you can draw a
line kind of northwest to southeast and
most neighborhoods above that line are
predominantly white and those beneath
that are probably black and so you still
are living with the generational divide
and the wealth gap that happens because
of that
the 1968 fair housing act outlawed
redlining nationwide
and city leaders here have pushed
projects like invest atlanta to
revitalize distressed areas
but many neighborhoods once deemed
hazardous are still more than likely
than others to consist of lower income
minority residents
we've had my childhood home for probably
over seven decades and i simply said you
know i'm going to try to make a
difference here
chicago native and real estate developer
lamel mcmorris
is trying to revitalize neighborhoods
without completely
gentrifying them or pricing out long
time residents
he calls that balance green lining i
want to make green lining
about neighborhood reinvestment and
neighborhood
redevelopment in june his firm green
lining realty usa
partnered with a dc based non-profit to
both build
and rehab residential properties in
woodlawn an
area rich in culture it's a setting for
lorraine hansberry's play
shaped by housing discrimination a
raisin in the sun
and the future home of the obama
presidential center
my goal is to be a resource and to be a
catalyst and to spur
investment it's almost like dropping a
pebble and watching a ripple effect
he's acquired vacant abandoned and tax
delinquent properties
and sells them at below market rates
buyers must be community-based
developers who then rehab the properties
and sell them to prospective homeowners
if you're really serious about
neighborhood transformation
it's not going to get done by simply
building new homes on vacant lots
and rehabbing blighted properties right
i've also had to make an investment in
my grammar school across the street i've
also had to
partner with the ywcf chicago i've had
to work with various community groups
that are working with gang bangers and
trying to get kids off the street
so it's a 360 degree transformation so
it's one thing to be
interested in the financial gains but we
also have to be involved
and engaged and just as concerned around
the social gains
so the development corporation owns this
whole block
just about minus one property on the
corner
back in atlanta shanae joseph runs the
historic district development
corporation
a grassroots organization founded by
coretta scott king
to preserve the martin luther king
junior historical corridor nearby
the houses that you see in this
neighborhood were either vacant lots are
just dilapidated
and so within 40 years hdc alone
has built or rehabbed about 121
single-family homes
we've built about 500 units and 40
thousand square feet
of commercial space but that hasn't been
without challenges
a majority of affordable housing here is
owned by non-profits and churches
much of it unsubsidized so hddc
can't easily profit off of its
investments
what you've done in 40 years bigger
development operations been able to do
in
two to five they've been able to do that
with
quite a bit of resources it's the
resources that aren't exactly afforded
to us
we've basically had to create something
out of nothing
and and to be able to do that almost
single-handedly
is an accomplishment that we don't take
lightly despite the practice being
illegal black loan applicants are still
turned away by banks at a higher rate
than white applicants
the widespread use of redlining has
allowed generations of white americans
to build wealth through equity in homes
and businesses
further widening a wealth gap african
americans have yet to rebound from
we have a cat cafe on irwin street
it is a cafe in which you pay money to
pet cats and so you're saying
you can give money to pet cats
yeah but you can't give money to but i
can't seem to get money to revitalize
one of the oldest african-american
streets in america
showing that on paper in black and white
joseph says
is key this is a sketch
of all of the projects that are planned
and in process
on auburn avenue you're looking at about
half a billion dollars
of redevelopment so this is a good
investment
this is absolutely a good investment why
well this is good because
you have you're working with
stakeholders that already own their
properties
right so you're not having to deal with
acquisition but more importantly what
you're doing
is you're reinvesting back into your
community that's going to continue to
prosper
time and time again it's what kimberly
alexander's family did
buying the property across the street
which before the pandemic was home to
several businesses
invest atlanta has been an integral part
of providing capital for businesses
but i still say there needs to be the
private sector
that gets involved and developers that
want to make
this city live up to its
you know creed and you know we mentioned
the pandemic
you know wreaking havoc on businesses it
also has a health impact and there's a
connection with redlining
in that you know folks who suffer from
asthma and copd and diabetes and obesity
in larger numbers african-americans
that's because
the the desperate effects are due to
that they don't have access
to health in hospitals they're just not
in those neighborhoods
so it's still impacting if you're
dropping a pebble
and seeing yeah